hey guys welcome where are we on Friday
we are almost at lunchtime so we are we
are desperately close to this time hands
up who's coming to PubCon today yes give
yourselves a round of applause it's a
it's a fantastic fantastic event we've
got these cool t-shirts that you're
gonna be seeing people wearing it's
gonna be a lot of fun if you don't have
a ticket yet about one hour ago there
were six tickets left so if you're still
interested I can't remember which pub
it's at but it's somewhere nearby six
tickets get on that now if you if you
want to be coming so we have got a lot
of content to cover today so I'm just
gonna jump straight into things from the
looks of this picture you can guess what
I like and that's beer my name is Ben
who likes beer on Twitter and you can
find it everywhere else like that I run
a company called pinch which is the
shirt I'm wearing a little startup out
of Brizzy if you're interested in
payments if you've heard of stripe if
you're heard of PayPal these kind of
things
hit me up because we're young we're
early were hungry and we're keen to
solve a bunch of problems so let me know
about that sir speaking of which the
thing we're doing today is talking about
identity server and building AP is for
developers so that you know you're in
the right room what we're going to be
covering is basically some API design so
we're going to walk through what I
consider to be a good design just so we
can see what I've got going on and then
the second half of this is going to be
adding identity server to protect
everything okay and I'm going to show
you a fairly real-world in fact a very
very real-world application here okay
this is my actual production code it's
what's shipped right now I'm on the
master branch you are looking at what is
in prod and therefore if you see maybe a
key here are there if you see a secret
if you see something that's not not
right be quiet
come tell me come tell me afterwards but
basically I also want to start this talk
with some
notable news because I don't know whose
was in Barry Dorrans talk or asp net
core a few people most of you then you
already know that identity server is
going to be integrated directly with
asp.net core in the future with 2.2 or
somewhere just after that and this is
incredible news because not only is it
going to make everything I show you
today redundant almost no I'm kidding no
it makes it really simple it's going to
make it for the file new people who just
want to get a project up and running
they're going to be able to make your
tokens and they're going to be able to
you know have proper authentication on
their api's right out of the box
almost it's going to be a few lines of
code so since we've got a lot to look at
today what I'm covering is what you can
do right now it's what's in production
and it's a more complex I would say than
normal implementation of an identity
server in asp.net core so a quick well
we're gonna go look at the code this
whole thing semi codes I have one slide
after this so a quick show of hands just
to gauge people's knowledge who is
currently using identity server for in a
real product ok it's maybe a third maybe
a quarter to a third of the room who has
dealt with any version of identity
server or a token server of some kind
okay we're looking at more of the room
there beautiful and who doesn't know
anything about this and is just keen to
find out what's going on ok a massive
chunk of the audience as well perfect
all right you're all going to get
something out of this talk today because
again I'm going to go through some what
might be pretty easy and pretty basic
things at the beginning and then we're
gonna ramp up and add an add an add
until we get to and so we get to the
final product so having said that let's
escape out there let's jump into pinch
and let's just quickly is this text size
with people at the back can you read
that you want a bit bigger yeah okay
I might have to do this a few times but
yeah we'll do something like that yeah
no worries guys just give me a yell if
I'm ever looking at something too small
so what we're gonna do NII I do
apologize but the stuff on the right
it's gonna be a bit small we can zoom
into it when we need to so what we're
doing is taking a look at my
applications called pinch we've got it's
a it's an asp.net core 2.0 at the moment
version running a side entity server for
the on the latest stable and what we're
going to look at first and I'll make
this a bit bigger to what we can look at
first is the the portal and I just want
to give you an example of what we're
going to do is a one request all the way
through so and we'll get this up as well
what we're doing today and let's just
pick any old thing payers and I'll try
and make this a bit bigger what's our
response okay so what we've done is
we've got a single page application
it's an angular app for anyone who's
interested I'm not really going to dive
into client-side stuff today okay this
is mainly focusing on the back end in
the api's but if you have questions
about that I'm happy to take them at the
end and what we've done is we've loaded
up a single page app with authenticated
ourselves and we've hit an API endpoint
and we've retrieved some data right so
far so good one thing that you should
note is that the API that this single
page application is hitting is the very
same API they exposed to developers to
do to build their products on and this
includes literally every endpoint and
I'll show you how you can lock down some
of them towards the end and it's it's it
just makes it a lot easier because I've
designed at API first I built the API
then I built the thing that uses the API
and this is a really good way of
building some of your own applications
if you're building green fields things
at least
and so what we're going to do first is
take a look at the API design for how
you know we went and fetch this data and
I'm also just gonna flick between that
and notes so I don't miss anything but
yeah basically we've just looked at
we've looked at one request I know you
know that was just to prove that it
actually does stuff but whatever where I
want to start as well bear with me
oh no I hit yes oh well is it developers
guys develop the place I want to the
place I want to start out is basically
looking at the the documentation okay
and I want to just going to describe how
I've laid out the the API and the
reasons for doing so cool little tool by
the way this this documentation
rendering things product called readme
i/o it can take in swagger files and it
lets you add more documentation to that
kind of stuff so a little quick tidbit
there but the way I kind of outline my
API is ignoring the authentication for
now is kind of with an entity okay so if
you've been if you've seen anything
restful before you'll know that you
usually add an entity and then you know
you'll use your get and put and post and
delete to go and access those things but
if you take a look at my API for things
where it's not necessarily straight
forward payers is just API slash payers
we can look at the top here API dot get
pinch comdata you slash test so that you
know you're hitting the test system
slash payers and everything from test
before is like a base URL and then
payers onwards is our entity so for
getting a payer straightforward get
slash ID you'll get a payer you want to
list all the payers
it's just slash payers saving a payer
it's a post to slash payers
deleting a payer yes there's a delete to
pay a slash ID now this is all very you
know that's basics right where I like to
get a little bit different is for
example with functions that you want to
perform on entities so for example here
I've got payments that need to be
executed in real time so credit card
payments and so I go payments slash real
time and you'll make a post request to
that endpoint so I'm not afraid of
tacking on function names to the ends of
these URLs because I think it's the
easiest way to to think about it when
you think about what you're trying to
achieve so don't be so strict bit to be
like okay well I'm gonna go slash
real-time payment slash create you know
you don't have to think of it in a crud
way it works well for your basics but
don't be afraid to put on function names
as well and then for other things I
guess most of these are fairly
straightforward just yet gets so it's
all just entity based and function name
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
dive into saving a payer for a payment I
believe it was actually so let's quickly
bring and let's take a look at our API
project
okay so one thing to note here and I'll
go over the I'll go over the solution
structure in a minute as well we're just
in an asp.net core MVC project okay and
this is my API project what I've got
here is a payments controller similar to
other things you'll have seen and again
we're just going to start easy and walk
through what's happening so what we'll
do is we'll look at the post or the save
method here okay so controllers again
they should be relatively thin very you
know by the way who he went to Jimmy's
vertical slice architecture talk okay
fantastic that's a lot of the room so
what you'll see here is this isn't as
this isn't as articulately structured as
his stuff it follows it in the same vein
kind of accidentally but a lot of the
points I'll be making it roughly the
same thing and this is you know one
implementation of a similar architecture
that you'll see and so yeah we want our
controls to be relatively thin so what
I've got here is the post endpoint when
using verbs again this is a more
opinionated thing I'm going to use get
I'm going to use post and delete I don't
like put instead what I'll do is I'll
have a post and if you send me an ID
I'll update it and if you don't send me
an ID I'll just create it but what we
have here is the the payment save
request and this is a DT or a class that
outlines everything that you're
expecting to receive and in similar to
Jimmy's thing this is like that request
portion of the architecture and we can
have a look at this one here and it's
full of simple stuff right you've got
the idea of the payment if you have one
you get the payer ID some amounts some
dates and some other things okay very
simple we take that in from the body and
then we pass it immediately off to this
line 96 here a payment save options now
some of you will have used something
like Auto mapper or something like that
to do a lot of your left writes and this
project I've purposefully left
everything very explicit so you'll see a
lot of left right code
in here it's just to show off what's
going on and so we take in that payment
saver request model and we pass it
through to a payment save options model
and this is my kind of internal layer of
DT OS okay wherever you see options this
is for the service layer to receive
information and the reason I don't share
these two models together is because you
can add some special information to your
options layer that you really don't want
from your request a couple of examples
of this are the user ID so who is making
this request and things like IP address
and stuff like that you don't want to
ask that from your user you just want to
collect it and add it to that service
layer and you'll see here I'm passing in
the sir the the sub Merchant ID and
we'll go take a look at how that's
implemented a little later on when it
makes more sense but you can come in and
take a look at your payment save options
and these are these are again very
straight forward it's just a sister DTO
where we're adding things but then what
we're also doing is we're adding fluent
validation and a validation layer to the
service layer DT o--'s okay so what
happens here is that I'm just asking for
some few basic things who is using or
has used fluent validation before I came
out of the room that's good there's
simple things like you know not empty so
it's required you can make your own of
that it has a minimum payment amount and
I do you know some complex ones like
make sure you don't give me anything
that's not within the last 30 days
and so my validation will just jump back
near to the controller my validation
isn't performed until the service layer
so we'll get to that in a second
moving down still in our controller
method here I check if the response from
the service layer was successful and if
it was what we do is just double check
again whether or not this is a new
entity or an existing one by looking to
see if we were passed an ID if it is a
an update we'll return okay 200 if it's
a creation will return created 201 using
the created at route and if we had a
failure
we just post back to the error messages
that we got from the service layer
okay so the controller really doesn't do
anything other than pass data through
and then check if it worked and return
the correct response that's its
responsibilities and so yes let's take a
look at projections so you'll notice
with our response I've got this thing
here called from entity so one thing
that's really important is that you do
not return your EF for your entity
framework models back to the client okay
they're gonna serialize a bunch of
properties that you do not want sent
back so similar to Jimmy's architecture
again we have this concept of the
response DTO or the response model and
in my case I'm using this from entity so
response data is as an EF model and I'm
passing it to the from entity and I'm
just gonna jump into this and we'll take
a look we'll break it down in a second
so in my domain sort of project my
domain assembly with all my EF models
and stuff like that I also keep my d tos
in the domain layer as well the response
DT owes do a lot more transformation
than the requests ones so you'll see
some basic properties like ID amount and
description yada yada yada some things
like I want dates to be returned in a
specific way so I'll map the data that's
incoming to a private property and then
I'll expose a public property which has
a response body that transforms that
internal property there so that's how I
can control how things go back to the
user on a per property basis another
interesting one that I'm a bit
opinionated about is how I deal with
enums when sending enums down to the
client like so when you put API layer
anything you give to the customer that's
an enum I want it to be a human friendly
string okay you know snake case so it's
got the dashes in it and the way I
achieve this is using the display
property so you can see here for an enum
we've got you know scheduled processing
dishonored and this one's doesn't have
any you know multi-word enums but
basically you add the
thing that you want to return or you
want to pause when you know you want
them to give it to you and then use a
little handy thing called get display
name there's a blog post on how that
works but basically that'll grab that
display header for you and posit
automatically on the way in and render
it automatically on the way out so we've
got some properties we're matching
things here and one of the most
important parts about this is the
projection stuff who here has used
projections by that name I guess maybe
you've used it accidentally but whose
projections before okay that's probably
a quarter of the room projections are
really really cool basically what they
let you do is represent what you want to
transform you're just mapping one class
to a different class and if you've used
Auto mapper it's it's kind of automatic
actually which is fantastic but here's
the manual way of doing it
we're just mapping one class to another
but we're doing it in such a way that
it's not it's not executed in real time
instead we're describing how we would
match one thing to the other and the
power of that is that you can infinitely
nest these projections so one DTO can
have a different DTO that it nests and
then that one can protect a different
one and you can project collections or
single properties and when you pass this
all to a link statement or an EF and any
framework query it's going to actually
you know figure out what you're asking
for and write a select statement that
has just the fields you've asked for
okay so rather than going and getting
all the tables bringing it back and then
projecting it it sends it and it
translates it down into sequel which is
fantastic so you've got basic ones like
this you know ID and my response is
equal to the display ID on my entity and
then you've got more complex ones and
yeah you know it's real word code when
you see stuff like this but basically
yes so you can transform this is a
little bit hacky but basically you can
transfer in certain properties we get a
status out and set it as the status some
interesting ones here this line the
payer property is then just from entity
for something else so it's using another
nested projection and the attempts is
using a
projection as well so for single
elements you can use from entity and for
collections you can pass the projection
into a select statement and it will do
it for you
so yeah project projections are really
cool you should definitely I got a blog
post on this on a how it like literally
exactly it works you can dive into the
auto mapper code as well to see it but
it's a really good idea to be using
projections and yes beautiful okay so
we've kind of excuse me we've looked at
the controller okay we've got our
payment endpoint we have a post method
to save the payment it's it's pretty
anemic all it does is pass down into the
service layer let's go dive into the
service layer and take a look at what
that looks like so what we have here are
a few interesting things the service
endpoint risk you know receives and
options and options class yeah the
service endpoint receives an options
class that options class then is
validated and you can see that on line
178 pretty much every options DTO has
that validator inside it so we validate
first and we check if the the the
service layer DTO is correct
now what this lets you do is rather than
checking properties on the controller
level so websites that hit you will get
the feedback if you bring it down to the
service layer anything that's hitting
your service layer can provide that
validation feedback so if you've got an
IOT device or a console app or anything
else that needs to use your service
layer it gets the same validation that
the api and web sites do so we check
that the validation is okay we return
the error messages if it's not something
really important to look at here is
probably the service response so the
service response class is a predictable
way of always traversing the layers of
your services and having you know
success notifications and error messages
bubbled up properly okay so rather than
using exception
which I don't like doing I don't mind
that it's a bit slow I just find it a
bit awkward to use instead I'll have a
service response and a service response
of tea the service response holds things
such as a list of the error messages and
I use the validation failure message
everywhere so if you're using fluent
validation you can just copy the array
of error messages and dump it straight
in the service response if you have your
own failures you can just go new
validation failure and add your own
successful it's just if there's any
error messages so you don't have to keep
setting successful true everywhere and
then yeah if if that particular service
call you're making needs to return data
you've got service responsive tea to
return that data and this is a fantastic
way to infinitely nest services if you
need to I wouldn't do it too far down
but one service can call another can
call another and errors will be bubbled
up correctly and even there's like a
created service response as well so you
can include things like ID but yeah so
service response you'll see every every
method in the services layer has a
service response and then we'll come
down and we'll we'll do a few things
something that's important and might
trap people out is that you've got to
validate that the who the user that's
you know calling this is the correct
thing so for me it's the sub merchant
that gets passed in that's the user
always validate your users and the
second interesting thing you might see
around the place is this concept of
display ID okay and so rather than
exposing the actual primary keys of
everything around the place whenever you
see a an entity or any kind of object
get pumped down to the to the user it's
always going to be a string like this so
it's got a little prefix at the front to
let me know what type of entity it is
it's got a random string okay and all
the URLs if you ever navigate anywhere
up the top here is is going to be that
payer ID or without entity and that's
just it's non-sequential it's just up
people just going oh I'm user - am I
let's try user 3 ok it stops people
doing that especially when you need to
expose some of these anonymously as well
you need to get payers to go land on the
page they don't use the system but they
need to use that
so that helps as well so I've got the
display ID for every entity that's
public and you'll see that in a minute
as well I mean most of this is fairly
simple we're just updating a payer pull
it out of the database it is a bit more
business logic in here but I'm not going
to subject you to that we'll jump
straight down to the up the create one
so creating a payment I've got a
shortcode service and here's actually a
really important tidbit who's using like
math dot random to generate random stuff
in their projects okay a few of you
who's aware that it's not thread safe
yeah exactly so one important tidbit
I'll just I'll share this with everyone
because it's super important random is
not safe to use as soon as you do any
kind of load testing you'll find out
that oh all of my payers that I've
just created have the same exact random
string as their ID so what you have to
do then is kind of pull out random and I
just show you the random service because
I think it's important I'll run this you
know you'll be a post this code later in
particular actually I think it got a
blog post on it but basically you need
to take care of a few collision points
because the the random object uses like
the current tick the current time
basically to decide it's seed but if you
have multiple threads running at the
same time it will break each other if
you have multiple instances happening to
be running at the same time they will
collide so you need a truly unique seed
for every random and one of the ways
that was suggested to me is take a look
at basically the machine name or the
azure environment name tag that with the
current manage thread ID tag that with
the current time and then use this
thread safe interlocked increment to
make sure that each seed for each
instance of the random service on the
thread and the process sorry is unique
I'll post this later because it's
difficult to digest at the moment but
you just need to be aware that random
isn't safe and if you're generating
random strings
you know load test is the easiest way to
find out that you've got collisions yeah
so I'm generating IDs generating this
kind of stuff we throw it straight into
EF who's using structured logging any
kind of structured logging beautiful
who's using Cerie log and seek you
beauty it's a truly fantastic tool I
highly suggest you go check it out if
you haven't already for anything that
goes wrong I mean you can just jump into
your local instance of it
I can't imagine coding without this kind
of stuff now I can just see what's going
on and I've created some test payers and
I've got the you know the data that I
pushed in I can see how long everything
takes and then I can go you know what's
the is it the mean of the you know
elapsed time or something like that and
do calculations like this and it
obviously isn't going to work now but
structured log is fantastic and see
objects that are in the in the database
you can log all the things that come in
and out of the service layer fantastic
bit of kit highly recommend and yeah
basically so that's the service layer
let me just check out me missed anything
validation yeah exposing error messages
is important I guess as well
be wary of what gets bubbled up through
the service layer so if you're if you've
got validation messages you can just
plug them all the way back up but
anything you put in the service response
consider that it will be viewed by the
user okay
don't put internal dev system bits into
your validation messages because yeah
they assume they get bubbled and kind of
separate them out from your system
logging use this system logging so your
logger to make the private bits and then
use the validation to surface what
happened we've gone through random
service not throwing that kind of stuff
beautiful all right so that's basically
the way I do ap is just at this point is
there any questions about that API
structure or anything like that anything
amiss it's very kind of straightforward
what we're gonna do perfect what we're
going to do is jump into identity server
stuff now so pretty much let me start
out by
taking a look at the go away taking with
the this solution architecture so what I
have at the moment is a an API layer and
a asp.net MVC core API layer I have an
asp.net MVC core authentication website
and that's where I'm going to be putting
identity server that's worth here I've
got a few things that we've kind of
touched on data is the entity framework
implementation stuff domain is where I
hold all my entities and D tos and
models and classes and stuff like that
there's a few other unimportant things
until we get down to web really services
I've got all my services in the service
layer again talking to Jimmy about this
vertical architecture stuff it's a good
idea to structure your services in a way
that's thinking about functionality and
not about entity but I've got a bit of a
mishmash of both and then finally web
now webs interesting webs the portal we
were looking at before and it is an
asp.net core MVC web site but all it
does is spin up an angular website as
well so it's an angular front-end and
basically that angular front-end is
authenticated by the auth website and
then it talks to the API and so what
we're going to do now is just jump into
the auth if I don't screw myself up here
okay so the goal is we have got our API
and we've taken a look at the payment
endpoint
we've got a an angular website what we
want to do now is let our developers go
and use our API okay and the thing we
need to start with is all right how do
we validate who's who and so one thing
you'll see in a lot of products is
they'll generate you a bunch of keys now
I've we'll focus on the development keys
here I have generated a merchant ID for
each merchant or user in my system I've
got a secret key and I've got a
publishable key okay so you would use
your Merchant ID and your secret key to
talk server-to-server
okay that's who you that's how you prove
who you are they used a publishable key
to put on is really just an identifier
on to anything that's public so that
publishable key you can throw onto a
script tag on your website just to pop
up your little face
it's embeddable it's shareable it's just
an identifier but the secret key is
secret to do not share that and what
we'll do with the secret key is take a
look at our authentication server so
what I want to do is kind of start off I
guess one of the questions here is who's
using asp.net identity just the straight
username password storage facility with
dotnet core only a few of you okay so
one of the one of the things I'll start
off then is by just taking a look at
some familiar code in the startup class
of our net core everyone's familiar with
dotnet core who isn't I guess is the
best way to do this a couple front ok
cool we're just setting up some services
at the moment so it shouldn't be
anything too strange hopefully so I'm
gonna skip through a bunch of this code
I'm gonna go straight to identity
now this is not identity server this is
asp.net identity its purpose is to save
usernames and passwords basically and
identify users so you've got some you
can see some stuff here where we've
basically removed a lot of the password
validation stuff for demos and we're
talking to entity framework so we're
just connecting entity frameworks you
know identity straight to energy
framework so it knows what tables to
store everything in and we're adding the
default token providers so it can
generate some data for us we add MVC and
and then there's nothing really too too
strange about this particular part here
Oh actually one tidbit if you're running
localhost
locally it's good idea to pull out the
ssl port and pass it to NBC though this
is gonna change in 2.2 I think 2.1 where
everything's https by default okay so
we've taken a look
yeah yeah it's a good idea taking a look
at identity what I want to do just for
context is also show you the user
classes and how I'm storing those keys
that I showed you before so taking a
look at a user for me
if you've used asp.net identity the way
that it's all automatically hooked up is
by inheriting from this identity user
okay if as long as you're in hearing
from this the user and all its
properties will be saved to the database
correctly and whenever a user logs in
you'll get all that information back
automatically the extra properties I've
chosen to add to my user is the concept
of a merchant this is like the idea of
like a company or an organization or
group or something like that so each
merchant can have several users they
don't at the moment but that's kind of
the idea if we take a look at a merchant
we'll see some familiar some familiar
properties when we get down to it we've
got our test secret key our live secret
key and our test publishable keys and
life publishable keys these are just
auto-generated on creation and you can
rotate them if you want but these are
just properties stored against the
merchant okay nothing special just some
strings and basically from there yeah
we've got we've got our strings and I
guess the the interesting thing here is
that when it comes to standard you know
standard logins so the the the website
the Embassy website case of ok I want to
identify a user we're using identity we
just go and plug in a username and
password and it redirects us to the the
website and we're logged in ok so that's
how we do asp.net Dental asp.net MVC
websites what we're interested now is
saying right how do we prove who the
user is logged in as and how do we
protect our API using bearer
authentication and identity server so to
do that what we are going to do is take
a look at it from thee I'll just bump up
the text size as well we're gonna take a
look at this from
the users perspective okay so just as
important as building the the API
protection is building an easy way for
your users to connect to your API and so
SDK creation could be a whole talk in
itself but what I'm going to do is just
show you a couple of interesting parts
about this and I'll just double check
what we want to get into yeah so let's
take a look at the payment controller I
guess I have an SDK with like a web
sample and so what we're looking at here
is an example of how a customer would
use my SDK to connect to the product and
it should be as easy as this we go okay
for whatever particular endpoint where
you want to hit we'll go to payment so
get API and you can see what endpoints
we have when it loads up it's probably a
bit small but there's the different
endpoints we have we're choosing payment
we're going to go execute real time so
there's a few important parts here let's
dig in to get API first and this is
going to get a bit mind-bending but get
API is just getting an instance of our
SDK for you basically this is going to
handle the storage of tokens and going
back and forth so what we want to do is
return a new API
given our merchant ID at our secret key
that we that I showed you in the portal
just before okay there's a few other
interesting properties probably is live
is the only other one that's interesting
is whether or not you want this to hit
the test system or the production system
excuse me but if we delve into this
pinch API there's a few kind of
interesting bits but basically the yeah
there's an HTTP client factory as well
in Henoko 2.1 i think it is they've
actually solved the HTTP client problems
that you that we've had recently and the
way that you handle HTTP clients but
really all we're doing is is setting
some properties including yeah our keys
I'm actually going to jump back out I'm
going to show you where
the actual stuff happens okay so given
an instance of our SDK we want to hit a
particular endpoint and you'll start to
see a pattern as we dive down into this
particular code execute real time is
basically just making a post HTTP HTTP
request to payments slash real time
given some data okay and the data that
we want back is payment detailed and the
data that we were given is real-time
payment save options if we dealt oh and
you'll see API response which is very
similar to the service response in our
service layer kind of same idea but lets
you bubble up errors if you dig into the
post HTTP method and I'm gonna go to
this guy you'll see that this one
basically abstracts things for us it's
accepting any URL and any object is data
and it's going and it's creating a
lambda function here that is building up
our request so you can see we're going
basically lambda and we're building up a
new HTTP request message in this case
it's a post given the base URI and the
URL we want to hit and we're accepting
some JSON body data now and you'll see
that the other posts are the same and
get and stuff like that and there's
stuff in there for files they all hit
this send HTTP method which if we go to
this guy what this does is it actually
requests an instance of the message so
line 90 it requests it executed that
function that lambda we passed it to
pull out the request that we're going to
make it goes a heads and it sets the
authentication header and in our case
that's the bearer authentication we can
dive into that as well let's let's get
deep let's get real deep the way it does
this is it asks to get an access token
and this part will go look at at the end
but assume that we can get a token it
adds that as a JWT or 'the header which
is basically just bearer and we'll dive
even deeper
which is just bearer space and then
token and that's on the authorization
header and that's set there so we've got
our token we've added it there we'll
jump back out it adds some other things
but we've set the author header back in
our send HTTP what it's going to do is
it's going to send that request it's
going to check if that request was
unauthorized if it was unauthorized we
have an automatic retry built in what
we'll do is we'll request a new instance
of that HTT message because you can't
reuse them so that's why we had the
lambda there so we can keep getting as
many of those as we need we'll reset the
author header this time with renew to
true so it's not going to use the case
token that we have in memory it's going
to go and ask for a new one and this
time it will run the request and if that
fails with authorize then you know we
give up we only have a one hit
unauthorized test there but basically
that is how it has unauthorized retry
and it's how it gets the token and puts
it rather it's how it's set to the
header what we're interested now is how
do we get that token so and I apologize
for jumping around a bit here but
basically up in our instance of the SDK
we have a method that understands how to
get the token so we'll just go down to
the bottom here it's called get access
token very very descriptive so basically
if we have an access token in memory
already it'll just return that if we set
the renew flag to true then it's going
to automatically whether it's going to
go and request and yuuri fokin an access
token there are two ways that you can
get an access token I'm going to be
looking at the secret key way and you'll
see here that we've got the client ID
and the secret key this is our merchant
ID and secret key when use these two
pieces of information to request an
access token
ignore the other one for now so
oops just took it from secret key there
we go okay now we're into it so what
we're doing here is spinning up a new
HTTP client we're setting our author
headers for our this request to basic
authentication okay and all this is
doing as its setting our username as
merchant ID and it's setting our
password as secret key wrapping that up
into a base of dedication a basic
authentication header and sending that
off to the token endpoint this is
identity servers token endpoint we set a
few parameters that we just need to set
this is in the documentation so don't
worry about remembering it and then we
hit connect slash token we hit connect
such token given that information and
then in the response that comes back is
our access token
so basically authentication to retrieve
an access token and there in that access
token we can then add that to our API
calls and then that's how the bear
authentication is completed so this is
kind of what it looks like from the
users side okay and the good thing about
having an SDK again is if we come back
to the payments controller they don't
have to care they just go hey get me an
API it's got this secret key in this
merchants ID okay it's really easy for
the user even though it's quite complex
for you to build and then one thing you
may not know is that when we hit any
endpoint well when we even load up the
site you can actually get access to this
token I mean I'm publishing it so you
can see it and inside it you can go to a
website called JWT io and what this will
let you do is it'll let you read the
information and I'll make this bigger
it'll let you read the information
that's contained in the token okay so
I've got things such as
and we'll just come up a little bit here
and you can even hover over it and it'll
tell you what it's about
so mbf is not valid before expiration
date the issuer who created the token
and in that case it's my local identity
server who's the audience that's the API
who's the client in this case it's my
portal pinch web the sub is the username
so the logged in user and that's just
the keyword from asp.net identity I've
got a couple of things in here like
submerged an ID one and two
that's just so I don't have to go
looking it up in the database every
single time it saves me database calls
we've got the merchant ID and we've got
the Scopes that it's allowed to get and
you'll notice here one of them is
merchants API keys just keep your eye on
that one but yeah so that's kind of what
it looks like from the from the users
point of view what we're going to do now
is show you how to get identity server
installed into your authentication
project now the first thing you want to
do is take a look at the QuickStart so I
want to forgot them in my yep there are
some great sample documentation for
identity server for this the one a
specifically recommend you take a look
at is the combined asp.net identity and
entity framework storage QuickStart this
is you can clone this repository and you
can take a look at how everything works
and how it's all hooked together it's a
really really good place to start what
I'm gonna do now is walk you through
that anyway and what I've got so let's
take a look at that so what we're doing
now is we're jumping into our fourth
project now as you remember it's an
asp.net identity sorry asp.net MVC
website ok standard web site with added
asp.net identity to save our user names
and passwords that's how we know who's
who and what we're doing is now adding
an identity server as a way of
generating tokens based on that
information so you'll want to jump in
and you'll want to add identity serve
and you get packaged this is the version
I'm on right now there's a couple of
helpers here you've got entity framework
and asp.net an identity this lets you
connect into any of your framework and
asp.net identity obviously and it's
super super handy
what we're going to look at after that
is SDK is the startup class so how do we
hook all this up okay so we looked
before at identity and how that was
wired up what we're going to do now is
take a look at some of the identity
service stuff I've got recapture there
as well now one of the important things
you need to consider is that the the way
these tokens are generated is that
they're signed by a certificate as well
so if we come out into our short bio if
we change literally anything in this
token the whole thing falls over okay so
the the server and the clients can you
know can use the public key to confirm
that the key has not been sorry that the
token has not been tampered with okay
and it's all hashed and stuff like that
so you can't alter the data that sits in
these tokens and the way it does that is
with a certificate if you're using Azure
you need to be careful that careful the
way that certificates are stored okay so
they're stored in the current users or
their my store in the current user but
basically all I'm doing here is finding
the certificate by its thumbprint from
the registry and then passing that down
into the identity server options so what
we've got here is the configuration for
identity server itself I'm changing a
couple of the login and logout bits I'm
adding the signing cert here you can use
a developer signing cert but I would
suggest making a cert upfront it's
probably better the way I'm doing the
next part is in memory so now that we've
got kind of a user like we have uses in
a database we have our API we need to
explain to identity server what we're
protecting okay and we do that in a
couple ways we need to set up the API
resources and the identity resources so
I'm actually just going to jump in here
and we'll take a look at the API first
all right so API we just need to give it
a name and it's just like yeah a name
and a scope pretty much we can say we
can give it a secret so that we can
prove that later on that the API is the
API that we're talking to we ask we can
include some claims for that particular
API will require some claims and we've
got this thing called scopes now scopes
are a way of kind of segmenting up your
API typically you'll just have one scope
for your API and I've just got API one
my whole API is called API one the only
scope it and really needs is API one but
I've also got this thing here Merchant
API keys now I'm just saying that this
is a particular scope that you can
request and that it exists as a concept
so keep that in mind as well but what
we're really doing here is identifying
that the API exists and describing it
the next thing we need to do is describe
the identity resources so not only the
endpoints that we want to protect but
also the data that we want to protect so
things like the open ID the username the
profile name and address and such emails
and I've also got a custom identity
resource that I want to protect and
that's information about my merchants so
I've got things in here such as the
their IDs their keys their you know
their name and stuff like that this is
information that people can request from
from the API and that I can you know
allow them to read if I want to so we're
just describing I've also got roles in
there but I'm just describing
information I want to protect so I've
described the API and the information
basically we'll just jump down here
there's an operational store so if you
want his identity server with entity
framework you can it's very easy when it
needs to generate tokens and remember
refresh tokens and all the other stuff
it needs to do it puts it in the
operational store
I'm just dumping this into a sequel
server this is the same code that we
would normally use to set up a sequel
server context up higher with with some
migrations as well and finally we have
the add asp.net identity as well and we
just need to point it
use a table basically just so that our
identity server knows where the users
are kept right it's just triple check
we've got everything that's a good point
actually with you and you'll notice when
I logged in you know there's a login
screen an account registration and stuff
like that the the good thing about
identity server for if you've used
identity server 3 is that the views and
the controller's for the authentication
like login and register and all that
kind of stuff you can they're just
standard embassy views and controllers
you can edit them you can change them
it's all fine it's all part of the
project is just a standard MVC project
where is in 3 it was kind of built into
the the NuGet package and you couldn't
change it very easily so that's another
thing to remember but let's see you've
taken a look at that yeah client store
ok cool
so we've identified what we want to
protect the next thing we need to do is
identify who is allowed access to our
resources and we do that with a client
store and what this does is basically
describe the system not necessarily the
user but the system that's allowed to
access our stuff so if we jump into I
guess a merchant client would be the
best one to start off with look at that
okay so all at once back is a client and
when you submit your merchant ID and
your secret key to me and I prove that
you are here you are I do it using these
so I get them the merchant ID comes in I
go ok great I'm gonna go look up the
merch at the database and I'll give it
back the company name I'll say they're
enabled here's their ID they have to use
the merchant ID and secret key to access
this like to generate a token that's how
they have to do it and here the Scopes
they're allowed to access so a typical
third-party developer can only access
these resources and you'll notice an
absence of the merchants API keys bit
here it's on purpose here the claims I
want to add to their token and here's
the token type so I want to give them
and so really we're just reaching into
the database and we're saying right
here's what that client looks like if we
compare that to a MVC client so this is
pinch web this is when you're using my
portal the client you're going to get
back is hard-coded so you'll see it's an
able pinch web it has to live on this
URI
I don't need consent so once you've
authenticated with my portal it can do
whatever it wants it doesn't have to ask
some other interesting things probably
the secrets so ignore that at least you
can see all of it this is how you prove
this is the port how the portal proves
it is who it is you know you can only be
redirected back to a specific URL and if
you have a look at the allowed scopes
this is the important part
it's got merchant API keys so my portal
can request this specific information
cool yeah and basically that's the kind
of that's the set up that you need to do
so we'll just jump back up into startup
all the way back here we go
so we've now identified the users the
validator themselves we've got our own
portal that's all of the configuration
you need to get the basics done really
this is why the Microsoft making the
integration and making it easy as such a
good thing because it skips a lot of
this stuff but once you've got that all
wired up down the bottom use identity
server just plunk it into your pipeline
just above where you want to protect and
once you've done that we can start to
look at the API or where they've got
about 6 minutes left so we've now let's
just quickly recap where basically we've
got our users in our database we'll get
our token server that knows how to look
into that database knows how to identify
people it knows what it's protecting and
those want information it's protecting
now it can generate these tokens and
we've seen from the user side how we can
use these tokens to send it to the API
we're going to do now is look at how we
protect the API and this is the beauty
of
the whole thing because it's actually
relatively simple the first thing you'll
need on your API project so we're
flicking over to our API project is to
use something like identity server dot
access token validation okay this is
going to build in the token validation
into your into your system and if we
take a look at startup we'll just jump
straight down to add authentication so
there's only a few things you need to
provide you need to provide the
authority this is just the URL for your
identity server ok where the token
server lives we require HTTP we say who
we are API one we're proving who we are
by using the secret here and that's
really all you need to do because once
you jump over to your payment controller
and if we this is what we kind of looked
at before when we're describing the API
if you come up the top what I'm doing is
using authorize ok the same authorized
tag you'd use in a standard MVC side and
this hooks into the bearer
authentication and it'll let anyone with
the valid token hit this endpoint but
even better than that is if we go over
to something like the merchants
controller okay so we have the same
authorized thing at the top here but if
we come down to the API keys section
okay we've got an authorized policy and
it suggests that we need merchants API
keys to go and fetch the keys and the
way we set that up again it's just in
startup just above our authentication
code come up here and we've got add
author ization okay and this is where we
can add some authorization policies if
you look at the merchants API keys post
policy I've got here the only thing it
needs is a scope of merchants API keys
if you remember in our client store the
only scopes you're allowed to request or
the only person that was allowed to
request that scope was the portal and so
this is how you can lock down systems
not just users into what they need to
use and as a really quick really quick
heads up one of the greatest things that
this lets you do
in your SD code one of the greatest
things that lists lets you do is it then
lets you not only authenticate you know
your user accounts okay so my portal can
login pinch users and pinch users can
use my portal if you then you build
something so I've got the Brendan the
Brendan website the Brendan website can
then also validate and use pinch users
using this connect functionality and the
beauty about this is the actual API code
and the SDK code isn't really any
different you're just getting a
different token so when we go to payers
we can see my payer information okay
this is the stuff that my developer
account can see this is the developer
merchant account but if I then want my
products this web sample to let other
pinch users log in and use my product
with their account you can go ahead and
connect a pinch and I'm actually just
going to do this in a separate window
will use Ben test3
no we won't because we're running at a
time basically we'll do is we'll just
use the currently logged in user
application so if you've ever seen like
connect to Twitter or Facebook wants to
tweet it Facebook once the post in your
behalf or wants to access your birthday
you can use the Kinect functionality
built into identity server to allow you
to access that stuff just go yes allow
and then you get the access token for
the user who has just agreed to use your
system so Brendan's website can use
pinch use of this and then the code is
identical so you can see here where I
had payor blah blah blah before now good
NDC Sydney alright I've got a different
users information and that's like a
really powerful feature that identity
server can give you as well so we've run
through like an absolutely staggering
amount of code right you can see that
this is what it takes to get even a rip
like it's a relatively complex setup
right you can read the QuickStart
documentation to get a handle of it but
the beauty of the announcement yesterday
is that basically Microsoft is going to
reduce literally everything I talked
about just now for one API instance and
one scope to the highlighted code there
okay it's going to be absolutely
fantastic is gonna be built-in it's
gonna be generated for you all you need
to do is add the appropriate NuGet
packages and it will figure out where to
store and save everything which i think
is a fantastic thing now I don't want to
eat into lunch so I'm going to go ahead
and say if you've got any questions or
if you need me go ahead and so you want
to know anything about your own
particular implementations of this come
up and ask me afterwards you can find me
online Ben who likes beer thank you very
much everyone for sticking it out
[Applause]